these peat family yahoo sports calling
and how are you Pete rich I'm great I'm
great condolences to your alma mater if
they had a nice run hey man they did
they did and and only to one team can
come out with six wins only one team can
come out with five and they were the one
that came out with five so well I guess
I'm not including a possibility of a
playing game but I think you know where
I'm going on that but I do want to focus
on on Villanova and and talk about how
they might be taking this sport to a
different place right now based on what
you're reporting do you believe that
that uh that they are in fact changing
the way that teams are going to recruit
and play this sport Pete well I think
we've started to see it a little bit
already rich obviously the the small
ball phenomenon is in full throttle in
the NBA and you know it's hard to
quantify it's like saying how many teams
run the spread offense you know there's
hard to say how many teams play small
dogs play a lot of different ways in a
game but I would think like maybe a
quarter or a third of college basketball
is this way but to just see how far
ahead Villanova is of the rest of the
field in college basketball is stunning
and you can't help but think there's
coaches sitting in their basketball
offices this morning going guys we're
gonna change the way we play we need to
find a five who can shoot we can't you
know we can't be tethered to a six foot
nine stiff in the middle if he's on
skills we need to we need to try to look
this way and play this way and look it
was not only did it work and there's an
errors of the NBA where the style that
worked was completely unaesthetic right
really college basketball right now is
completely unaesthetic and in a lot of
ways but this Villanova team I will
never forget the way the ball buzz
around the perimeter on Saturday night
against Kansas it was unlike anything
I'd seen there was just like a kinetic
connection between those guys and the
stat always remember from that game
Britches that Kansas didn't foul
Villeneuve on a shot to go to the line
for the game's first 31 minutes they
didn't tempt a free-throw until like the
nine-minute mark and it was basically
because they couldn't catch him because
there was such good spacing and the ball
moved that's such a precipitous pace but
Kansas Dan had a chance to foul so I
hope for the sake of the sport that we
see
things move this way yeah Pete and and
last night Michigan had a seven-point
lead and they were getting Brunson
frustrated they were switching expertly
to create problems on the three-point
line and and it only really halfway
through the first half given up one
three-pointer period against Villanova
and then D Vincenzo came off the bench
he was unbelievable tell tell me more
about this kid and who he is and and
what we saw last night Pete he is using
Michael Jordan of Delaware that is this
one of his one of his labels he is from
he is from Delaware he was an under
recruited guy I think his final two were
were shared Houston Nova but he was not
a guy that they had to beat off Kentucky
or Duke to get he was not like a big
McDonald's All American national recruit
he had actually on their title team year
he had played in ten games and started
one he broke a bone in his foot and so
he took a redshirt at that year so
someone asked him about the first title
team last nigh and he said he watched in
a suit on the bench which I thought was
kind of a good line I mean and he was
their sixth man extraordinaire this year
he started ten games I think but for the
most part he was the guy who came off
the bench and played starter's minutes
we saw him do to Alabama in the second
game of the tournament the same thing
he'd admission to get 18 in the first
half against Alabama and looked like
calling around about McHale bridges a
couple of weeks ago for a profile of him
he's obviously the the latter doing a
surefire lottery pick on Villanova a
couple NBA guys were like you know don't
be surprised if T Vincenzo ends up in
our league you know they didn't think it
would be immediately it could be
immediately now but he's a guy because
of his explosiveness I mean think about
that the best player I think you made
all night was he misses a shot in the
lane one of the very few and he's in the
cameras I need is a full or sprint down
it pins the ball on a block I forget who
shot it it might have been a Simpson I
think was Simpson who did that I think
it was and it and he pins the ball to
the rim and it gets stuck there I mean
that was just everything you want it was
that lettuce is it was unbelievable
hustle and then timing I I can't recall
guy who is that more aggressive and
violent put back dunks he's a violent
jumper if that makes sense
like when he launches towards the rim
there's something different about it
there's there's a level of athleticism
and twitch there that it's on a higher
plane that he had a couple foot backs in
Boston that I remember in the East
region sort of sitting up in press row
being like whoa that's different you
know you don't see that you don't see
that every day
so I mean what a what it what a great
story and I don't think we're if you can
sit back and say I hope Michigan didn't
play that well I know what they played
all right you know I thought they they
had a good game plan and then one guy
just came and it delivered a haymaker
and sometimes there's not much you can
do when he hit that heat check three in
the first half you are like okay this is
where this is going pretty high I was
feeling the same way and by the way that
blocked that on on Simpson a lot of my
fellow Wolverines on Twitter thought was
was a goaltend but the ball was never
above the rim I mean was that's why he
could pin it inside you know around the
rim right there but to me I thought it
the his most impressive block was the
two-handed one on Matthews was well I
just a wide open path to the basket had
seen and he look this kid D Vincenzo
deserved well the most outstanding
player he was absolutely incredible Pete
famil of Yahoo Sports here in the Honda
inside a report do you think Jay Reich
punched his ticket to the Hall of Fame
last night yeah and I think even if they
lost their rights all event coach I
don't think there's there's much there's
much doubt about that you wonder if he
gets a wandering eye rich you know it's
I think it's worth asking at this point
you win two titles in three years
you know Billy Donovan when I'm
back-to-back had found himself with the
water and I a few years later J
certainly I think has the temperament
and humility on an on an NBA sideline
unlike certain coaches in Lexington and
recently Louisville who went into the
when to the NBA without that temperament
in humility and failed spectacularly at
that level I I think Wright would be
able to relate to players because the
NBA's relationship managing as much as
it's certainly it's plenty of coaching I
don't want to demean or downplay that
but it's you know it's like anybody it's
like any job it comes back to people
right you work in sales you can work as
a janitor you can work as an executive
it comes out of people
that's where Jay Wright is a cut above
his peers in in college path and that's
not to take anything away from him as a
coach it's certainly we've seen and
refine a system and I think the legacy
of this final four richest player
development I think there's going to be
a renewed focus on okay let's get guys
better how do we get guys better I in in
the for Villanova games I saw in the
tournament I don't believe they
committed a charge because they jump
stop everything and they're in control
at all times and I just think there's
some little nuances that that are just
byproducts of a really well-run
fundamental program that you're right as
well the only reason why you know I'm
Jay Reich might want to jump is I know
because to me let's let's let's sit on
this one a little bit here Pete because
to me it might be like what's going on
in football where where you're seeing
guys instead of going pro just staying
and becoming the lord over a fiefdom
collegiately when the money is pretty
much the same right I mean why why would
Jay Wright want to bounce to the NBA
unless unless what you and Pat 40 have
been reporting on is going to start
changing the entire landscape of the
sport I mean what what did you hear
about your reporting over the last
several weeks with the tournament play
kind of pushing that to the to the
background Pete look it's ongoing rich
and you can't look at that story in like
a a micro vacuum you have to look at it
from a macro and I probably was asked
this about 6,000 times in San Antonio my
colleagues had 40 probably another 6,000
times but when's the next rügen is
everyone's impatient you know I think
that's probably a societal thing more
than more than everyone more than
anything else and the final of the three
trials tied to the case is set for April
of 2019 so at the very least we have
another year of revelations of this
hanging over this board potential people
flipping on you know people within the
game like there is a lot of golf left to
play there we probably just spend
the sixth hole we want to start using
masters analogies so in other words Jay
Wright would want the wanderlust just
because what some mba owner just throws
a ton of money in him where he just
couldn't even be able to stick around
there and or how about this new
challenge right I think it would just be
a new chat like a certain point you want
a new challenge
if he stays another decade villanova
becomes the duke of the north east if
it's already isn't hmm all right so when
it all is all said and done and I found
it interesting you say player
development is gonna be what's taken
away from this from this tournament
we're gonna see more and more people try
to be like Villanova copycat sport
situation yeah and Michigan quite
frankly I mean they unit you know you
follow a clothes rich like Momo vogner
wasn't exactly you know someone that the
coaches were lined up on the sidelines
to see in in Berlin and you can kind of
go through that they certainly have very
good players you don't want it to mean
them but you know John Beilein wasn't
that that's what is what Michigan
State's roster on paper was
exponentially more talented that than
Michigan SACEUR no one's gonna dispute
that and Michigan had a much better
season so who do you think's got the
better Pro prospects D Vincenzo D
Vincenzo or or vogner what do you think
OD Vincenzo I mean Bob sure is a nice
skilled college player who fits well in
that system I don't know if he has the
pop and the athleticism so really treant
like who is he on the next level I have
a hard time wrapping my mind around that
Pete thanks for the time we'll chat down
the line great report Rick appreciate
you we got a same team that's a peat
family so Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience